you have so much pain in you
you so much rage there's a new Marvel
series coming to Disney plus friends
it's called Ekko and it's based on the
Marvel character of the same name a deaf
superhero that first appeared on the
show Hawkeye making this a classic
spin-off and let's face it the MCU is a
lot of moving parts so here's everything
you need to know before the show Echo
premieres on January 10th you and
I are the same
before you watch Eko the show let's get
to know Ekko the character Mya Lopez AKA
Ekko is a def Native American who
started showing up in the comics as a
supporting character for Daredevil and
later Ronin and others she is an
incredible expert in Marshall arts and
hand-to-hand combat along with being a
highly skilled Olympic level athlete fun
fact did you know that you could
actually race walk in the Olympics
they've thought of everything anyways in
the comic she also has the ability to
perfectly mimic other people's movements
but that's something that the show is
actually going to move away from after
director and executive producer Sydney
Freeland called it kind of lame in
variety I mean I guess we'll take her
word for it now Maya's tribal backstory
was also changed and made more authentic
for the show compared to the comics
where it's more of a hodgepodge of
imagery according to Freeland Maya's
father was a leader of the criminal gang
known as the tracksuit Mafia run by the
big baddy Kingpin when Maya's father is
killed by Clint Barton AKA Ronin during
the blip she's basically raised by
Kingpin and follows in her Father's
Footsteps that is of course until she
learns that Kingpin is the one who
orchestrated her father's death more on
that in a second but basically heading
into this show she's got some serious
emotions bottled up and she's ready to
blow now Maya is played by alaka Cox a
Native American who is born deaf and
who's casting as his character in
Hawkeye marked her debut role I mean now
she's got her own show I bet that wasn't
on her 2024 bingo card Ekko picks up
where Hawkeye left off for this
character so let's do a quick recap the
Disney plus miniseries Hawkeye features
Jeremy Runners Clint Barton and Haley
steinfeld's Kate Bishop as they come
face to face with enemies from Clint's
past now when we first meet Maya Lopez
she is the commander of the tracksuit
Mafia criminal gang and working for her
adoptive Uncle Wilson Fisk AKA Kingpin
Maya's on the hunt for revenge against
Clint for killing her father but she
eventually learns the truth about
Kingpin being behind it and turns on him
now FYI there are Hawkeye spoilers ahead
I mean technically everything I just
said was a spoiler but this is really a
spoiler as that show was ending and
Kingpin was getting away as bad guys do
he was confronted by Maya who pulls out
a gun and then a gunshot is heard Q the
spin-off series now that we know what
happened here's what will happen going
forward so what I can tell you guys is
this after the events of Hawkeye which
happened in New York City Maya goes back
to her hometown in Oklahoma for this
show and it's there that she has to come
to terms with some things in her past
while also reconnecting with her family
and her Native American Roots now what
is that fancy synopsis mean exactly for
starters we'll get an origin story and
plenty of stuff surrounding her father
and his death director/ EP Freeland
described the series as quote an
exploration of trauma of course Maya
also no doubt will have to answer for
what happened in Hawkeye after turning
on and potentially shooting Kingpin all
I know is that this is going to be
really fun now of course Maya is not the
only person that you'll be getting to
know so here are a few more characters
Vincent denafo is back as Kingpin the
New York Crim Lord and Maya's adoptive
Uncle first showed up in the Netflix
show Daredevil and then again in Hawkeye
and speaking of Daredevil our boy
Charlie Cox is back too he's now popped
up in a handful of MCU projects lately
including Spider-Man no way home
She-Hulk and Hawkeye and after reprising
his role from Hawkeye is Zan McLaren as
my his father William Lopez we also know
that Dey Jacobs who's a star writer and
director on the show reservation dogs
will have a pretty big part in this but
her role is still unknown and another
recognizable face you'll see is that of
Graham green as a character named Scully
he of course was Oscar nominated for his
role in Dances with Wolves and is always
great and spoiler Cosner actually Dances
With Wolves wolves in that movie there's
Talent behind the scenes too so let's
meet some other folks the show was
created by Mar and dare whose biggest
and best credit is working on Better
Call Saul where she Rose through the
ranks I mean say less am I right joining
Dar as co-writer is Amy rarden who has
worked on shows like Jane the Virgin and
the new Charmed and I mentioned Sydney
Freeland a Navajo filmmaker who leads
the directing team and serves as one of
the executive producers so pretty much
what I'm trying to say is it sounds like
the show is in good hands good hands
good hands I mean do you guys hear that
is there an echo in here I'm just
kidding you know I had to do it at some
point okay friends well that's
everything you need to know before the
show Echo premieres on Disney Plus on
January 10th I'm Nas Perez thanks for
watching and be sure to rate and review
the show at Rotten tomatoes.com
[Music]